que dire de cette élection je crois que
ça a été beaucoup rappelé c'est
finalement le coronavirus qui s'est
invitée comme un élément très
déterminante dans l'élection municipale
et c'est particulièrement vrai dans
l'arrondissement du xviiie où les
quartiers populaires ont eu un taux
d'abstention absolument record je crois
que beaucoup d'électeurs n'avaient pas
la tête à ça et compte tenu des
difficultés du contexte quand notamment
bien sûr aux questions de santé mais
aussi à la question du travail vous
savez combien d'autres et
arrondissements la question du travail
et est très très importante avec un taux
de chômage endémique et puis bien
évidemment la garde des enfants donc
tout cela beaucoup perturbé en effet le
les résultats et le fonctionnement de
cette élection que ce que vous dites ça
dit la médaille c'est que de toute façon
même les résultats du premier tour sont
contestables et vont être contestées non
je ne dis pas ça puisque finalement la
règle c'est que tout ce qui est exprimé
vos démocraties et donc moi je pense que
le président de la république a eu
raison de suivre l'avis du conseil
scientifique et des représentants des
forces politiques en en maintenance est
ce premier tour et je dis simplement que
en effet il ya eu sans doute des
interférences dans cette question et
c'est pour ça que bon là aujourd'hui le
bon résultat de premier tour de notre
maire sortant c'est un peu ce qu'on vous
râlez chaîne nationale c'est la prime au
sortant
que ce soit les gens de dps ou même deux
des républicains donc cette prime au
sortant est très importante surtout dans
un contexte où aujourd'hui où les
problèmes en effet de sécurité au sens
large
les gens avaient besoin peut-être de se
repérer par rapport à quelque chose
qu'il existait je tiens à dire aussi que
notre parti est un jeune parti puisque
vous savez qu'il existe que depuis trois
ans depuis l'élection du président
macron et que l'enracinement ne se sont
pas en une génération ou dans dix
huitième nous avons choisi donc candidat
d'agir puisque c'est pierre yves
bournazel et je peux vous assurer qu'il
a fait
il ya d'excellents scores puisqu'on en
est à près de 17% ce qui est très très
notable quand on sait que le 18e et
quand même un arrondissement de couches
ça va être compliqué de commenter ces
résultats puisque on aura probablement
pas de second tour
néanmoins vous vous parliez du
gouvernement qui prend régulièrement
avis auprès des experts mais beaucoup
d'experts disent il faut prendre des
mesures radicales de confinement ce soir
on le voit beaucoup de pays où même le
venezuela ce soir est en quasi
confinement pourquoi pas là vous lui
avez raison mais vous avez raison mais
de cibler il faut pas juger des
décisions à l'aune du rétroviseur
c'est à dire que mon moment et vous
l'avez bien vu ce gouvernement joue la
transparence en l'état des éléments ils
ont pu disposer vous voyez comme la
question est très évolutive et donc
c'est normal que des décisions d'hier
peuvent apparaître complètement
inadaptés aujourd'hui aujourd'hui en
effet chaque fois qu'on vous avez
entendu tout à l'heure de votre
reportage
donc le premier ministre avait rencontré
réunir le conseil scientifique de tous
les experts sanitaires et les
représentants des forces politiques je
crois que c'est à partir de là qu'il
prendra une décision parce que le risque
est grand que vous savez une soyons
accusé d'une vision extrêmement
autoritaire et faut que absolument les
choses soit vexé de façon consensuelle
et appropriée par les cendres par
l'ensemble des français d'ailleurs
normal que cette étape puisse permettre
le consensus par rapport au renforcement
sans doute des mesures qui vont être
contents fadila mehal il vous devez
entendre les inquiétudes les angoisses
de vos administrés dans votre
arrondissement
dans ce contexte là est ce qu'il faut à
tout prix attendait les avis des experts
des scientifiques et pourquoi pas mais
quand on nous le reprocherait monsieur
ce que je peux vous dire c'est que les
conditions qui ont été mises en taxes
d'ailleurs je salue tous les salariés
les personnels de la mairie du 18e qui
ont fait un travail remarquable et je
peux vous assurer que dans tous les
bureaux de vote dans lesquels je suis
passé les choses se sont extrêmement
bien passé c'est à dire que tout
les précautions les mesures de
précaution ont été prises et il n'y a
pas d'inquiétude particulière par
rapport à ceux qui étaient là donc je le
peux témoigner que de ce que j'ai vu par
contre beaucoup on essaie notamment dans
les quartiers populaires se sont
abstenus et donc la peur sans doute est
réelle elle est dit
il faut en tenir compte mais vous savez
nous sommes dans un état de droit
et aujourd'hui il n'est pas possible
après avoir pris une décision majeure
est important politiquement qu'on puisse
revenir en arrière sans que les avis
soient pris elles sont que en effet tout
cela soit mis à l'honneur du consensus
un dernier commentaire ça dit la menace
sur le comportement des français qui est
on les a vus aujourd'hui étaient
massivement assis dans les parent peut
être à bonne distance mais les groupes a
été pour le moins compact moi je crois
que la prise de conscience est en train
d'arriver elle se fait difficilement
notamment pour les jeunes puisque il ya
ce sentiment d'éternel finalement il
d'immortalité qui réside à leur vie et
c'est tant mieux parce que ça donne
beaucoup d'énergie mais je crois qu'au
fur et à mesure quand on voit un peu les
statistiques
alors c'est vrai ces statistiques
parfois certains considèrent comme
mortifère mais je crois que c'est
important de dire les choses aussi et de
voir comment la maladie progresse et qu'
elle n'est pas inéluctable puisque il ya
des barrières qui dit il faut simplement
les mettre en taxes c'est une question à
la fois de responsabilité mais aussi de
solidarité parce que les jeunes doivent
penser qu'ils doivent aussi protéger les
plus âgés et travailler sur ce lien
intergénérationnel
donc moi je pense que les choses
arrivent c'est vrai que un moment but on
a senti qu'il y avait eu un tournant
avec ce passage à la période 3
finalement et aujourd'hui je pense qu'il
fera très certainement discuter de façon
très très franches la salle sont bons on
peut encore améliorer ses barrières un
commentaire sur le score d'agnès busan
ce soir peut-être à écouter c'est un
score vous savez la campagne a été
émaillée de difficultés vous connaissez
de dernier
incident en date avec le retrait de
benjamin griveaux donc ça paraît facile
pour elle
heureusement les équipes étaient
constituées le programme était quand
même construit puisque je rappelle qu'il
ya des groupes de travail qui ont
vraiment consolider ce tous les axes sur
lesquels elle est intervenue
elle a porté une patte particulière en
fin de parcours sur la caution de la
solidarité la question sociale et
notamment sur en effet le lien qu'un
générationnel et la composition qu'elle
a faite par rapport au maintien à
domicile des personnes âgées
je pense qu'il va manquer du temps très
certainement mais ce que je peux vous
assurer de ce qu'elle est venue très
très souvent dans le 18e c'est que son
écoute sa compassion mais aussi sa
volonté d'agir pour transformer la
réalité très concrète s'en aille
d'ailleurs idéologie mais avec
pragmatisme a beaucoup en tout cas
permis à beaucoup de des lecteurs d'être
rassurés de voter pour elle la preuve
dans un arrondissement de souvent qui
est très je dirais radicaliser parfois
si elle a fait quand même un très bon
score puisque ces deux scores de la
moyenne alors que en réalité c'est un
parti nouveau
c'est à partir jeunes et que aujourd'hui
je pense qu'il ya tout ce travail dans
rapidement de sédimentation qu'il faut
faire merci beaucoup fadila mehal
d'avoir répondu à nos questions ce soir
en direct et vous aussi